loving this vibe tonight what was the
look you wanted to go for well i had to
have a few different changes because i'm
doing a few performances so this is for
the first performance and yeah i just
want it to be bright okay so two looks
tonight you got an outfit change i do
have an outfit changer okay so you are
nominated and performing tonight five
nominations how does that feel
uh i don't know because i've been doing
it for long enough that i've turned up
at places where i've been nominated for
like 15 before or not one one so like i
i don't know i don't know what whatever
happens happens i i love being at these
things i love performing at these things
but if i don't walk away with anything
it's not the end of the world what can
you tell us about your performance
because we do know that is happening no
matter what uh i open up with overpass
graffiti and then i play shivers halfway
through okay you know so ed earlier this
weekend we talked to your bestie taylor
at her all too well premiere and she was
gushing over you he's a wonderful
wonderful friend so yeah i love him
talking about how much she loves you and
how much your friendship no matter the
distance no matter the years that go by
it never changes and you're always there
for her what does that mean to you she
is a very very good friend of mine i've
known her for about 10 years and uh um
it's just nice to have someone in the
music industry who goes through the same
sort of things um we're both the same
age we both write songs from our heart
and uh yeah it's a pleasure knowing her
and you get to work together with one of
your best friends which is awesome and
with that being said there are a lot of
rumors on that she is the american
artist on the remix
the joker and the queen what do you have
to say
uh do you know what with with with lots
it's nice to have surprises in life it's
nice to have surprises so uh yeah you're
taking a page on her book and you're
leaving us a lot of easter eggs that
wasn't actually me that was the that was
the director uh who he had the um
he had the leather jacket made so it
might be an easter egg for something
else it could have been for run you know
interesting god you got all you got our
minds wondering now ed last question for
you how's your baby girl doing she's
great she's walking she's talking
she's like my parents at the moment and
uh yeah having a good time what was the
first word
what was her first word when she started
talking see i'm not sure because she's
been saying dad for a while but pointing
it randomly so
um yeah i'm not sure oh my gosh well god
bless you and have so much fun tonight
how much of a party is it here in
budapest at the ema
yeah i mean there is no after party
because it covered but we had a good
time yesterday well you're bringing the
party here
[Music]